[Music]
you know i'm sure you're aware of star
trek picard going on
and and patrick stewart's back doing it
and
um there's a lot of interest on uh with
star trek
on paramount plus which is now it's
called the streaming service
is revisiting o'brien in some way shape
or form
something that you're interested in or
is it something that it's from your past
i'm happy
it happened and i think
i've always felt like seven years days
it was long enough you know
um i i yeah
yeah i i don't i don't know i mean as i
get older you know you kind of get a bit
nostalgic about
about um some of the stuff you've done
in the past and
it might it might be nice to go back and
you know
uh have a look at it again but i i don't
i mean i don't believe it very often i
mean
generally speaking over the years i've
been i would have been reluctant to
to go back to what brother and i have to
say but yeah you know you never see
it ever i don't know if you are aware of
this but
um there's a an animated star trek
series called lower decks
and in a recent episode they talked
about o'brien
and how he's the most important
starfleet character of all time
wow finally finally they got it right
huh